one of the craziest stories in American
history involves a bridge an elephant
and a man who couldn't take Noah as an
answer the years 1867 in the city of
Chicago has become the main trading Hub
in all of the Midwest St Louis is
jealous and they want to take the number
one spot so they decide to build a
massive bridge over the Mississippi
River the problem is that steamboats
which travel up and down the Mississippi
River they don't want to be stopped by
some new bridge so the city of St Louis
decides they've got to go bigger than
ever and this new bridge design will
require the use of structural alloy
steel for the first time in any major
construction project in the United
States this is where Andrew Carnegie
comes in his company takes the designs
for the Eads bridge and they build a
stunning Steel Bridge that defies all
previously known limitations there's
only one problem though no one actually
trusts that the bridge is safe enough to
cross so what does the company do they
walked a massive elephant across the
bridge to prove that it was safe why did
they do that at the time it was thought
that elephants had special instincts and
they would never walk across an unsafe
structure